All right, it's your turn.
Implement a CursorLoader
in the forecast fragment
to load the cursor used
in the cursor adapter.
You want to pass zero in for the flags
when you create the cursor adapter as
the loader will now be responsible for
re-querying when data changes.
Also, it's easiest to
have ForcastFragment
implement the Loader Callbacks.
If after you're doing all of this,
your app still displays the weather,
you've probably done it right.
Make sure to check that you are using
the support library versions of all of
our classes.
Otherwise, you won't get
Android 2.3 compatibility.
I've provided the exact import
statements you need to use
in the instructor notes below.